so that brings me to one of the first
topics here that we're gonna hit is uh
the denver broncos potentially being up
for sale they're not yet they had a
great owner for years pat bolin won a
couple super bowls
now they're fighting they're having some
infighting as far as ownership with that
team and it's probably going to go up
for sale next spring and you're hearing
big names attached to this one one of
them is jeff bezos you figured it
eventually
the self-described nerd space cadet
would want to own a football team
because his girlfriend probably wants
him to number one you also hear jay-z
being thrown out there repeatedly as a
name and then you're hearing peyton
manning right now you know you're not
hearing it from peyton manning but we
were talking about this after we went
into the hall of fame a few weeks ago
what's the next move for him ownership
clearly he's going to have to jump on
board some ownership committee but do
you think this is the way it's kind of
tracking for for payton and he's got the
big profile right now on monday night
football with that alternate broadcast
for espn well he's also got his home now
in in denver and elway's also throwing
his hat in the mix from what i've
read so does peyton and elway kind of
come together and and they need more
money as well as they done they don't
have nfl ownership money you know the
rule in the nfl is you have to have if
you're an owner at least 30 has to come
from you if you're the primary owner
that's why they're 30 of the wholesale
or 30 of whatever your majority stake is
30 of the sale so in this case if
they're valued at about 4 billion it'd
be 30 of that which some people are
saying rules out jay-z 1.5 bill yeah so
but jay-z will have to attach himself
yeah but like some all-stars true but i
think that that lead guy has to have 30
now i don't know if he can just latch on
to somebody else that does have the
money but when you said elway i think of
elway jay-z if you need investors man i
got i just hit a five-team uh parlay
over the weekend
aren't parlays sucker bets guys but
that's of course they are all right of
course
lotto tickets but you know somebody's
got to win you don't have to do that
much right it's for fun so it's it's
there's only upside down
from the franchise talk but here's the
cool thing we talked about with jerry
jones a few weeks ago right so what did
pat bowling buy the denver broncos for
78 million dollars in 1984. 78 million
you know what now it's gonna sell for
four billion you know what always
happens with these things is is there's
always somebody waiting in the weeds
like steve cohen with the mets you're
gonna let jlo and a-rod and everybody
tell you exactly what the market is
they're gonna let them beat away all the
other goldman sachs guys and then
they're gonna come in at the last minute
and say oh yo so it's really 4.5 billion
i got 4.7 yeah let everybody else do
everything they can to get every penny
that they know
max out their leverage and then step
into the lesson do you think do you
think bezos can can handle 4.7 billion
guys i don't know i mean there's houses
there's one bedroom condos in florida
that are going for 125 market value you
think that this thing might end up in
the 5.56 billion range you know just
like the clippers when steve ballmer
bought it when you have unlimited funds
the price is whatever you want it to be
right and no one thought the clippers
were worth two billion dollars when he
bought them in 2013 or 2014. now he
bought the land where the forum is on
good good for steve bomber too though
man it's it's good to see you know
something good happened to you know rich
tech white guys yeah for once when you
consider the percentage of microsoft was
able
right
i don't know how he ended up with so
much stock have you ever seen this he's
worth a hundred billion have you ever
seen the videos of him and bill gates
dancing on stage and stuff like that
he's just a maniac
he's he's hard he's hard to watch you
know i've seen him at games in person
and he's just he makes you feel
uncomfortable just being innocent these
are the people ruling the world right
now man i know i know okay
oh denver's actually tenth uh ranked or
valued franchise yeah so that's a good
buy
10 you don't get a lot of top 10
franchises that are up for sale
that seems so high yeah but they have
such a loyal fan base maybe they own
this thing i don't know who owns the
stadium if it's the city or
that's a big part of it i don't know
either but they're about 3.75 i think
billions that's why they're setting it
around four but you're right depending
on the market it'll go over four billion
dollars it comes down to i mean that's
the biggest boys club there is in the
world they own sunday they own a day
but they also decide who gets to play in
their group right so they will decide
who they want to own the team i don't
know if they want jay-z as far as an
ownership i don't know if they want jeff
bezos do you think they would want jeff
bezos do you think jimmy johnson robert
kraft all these really strong owners in
the league would welcome in bezos yes
yeah because of amazon prime because of
tv
i also think they'd yeah they would and
they'd also make him overpay so that
just sets the value higher for every
other single team in their in the nfl
there's got to be diversity though in
ownership that's it's it's coming jay-z
may not be the right one but it's it
it's it's got to happen there's been
enough ex players that have expressed
interest there and michael jordan's done
it it's just not that easy it's just not
easy to put five billion dollars
together diversity for diversity sake is
the wrong way to go about it anyway like
artie moreno out in la los angeles
angels did it the right way made his
money invested his money you know it
doesn't matter that that he wasn't you
know
the right type of minority i suppose but
it's like you know listen man you you
are are you suggesting i i guess jeff
that
they should take somebody that no no i'm
just offering less money no it's gonna
you're right it's gonna be driven up but
there'll be someone that'll come in with
the the market value because at that
point when you get the group together
and they'll be the wall street guys 4.5
poor points well right here in miami
derek jeter wasn't the one that put up
all that money for for uh you know he
leads the group right so but i mean
that's i guess what i wasn't really
understanding what you were saying
earlier derek jeter didn't have to put
up thirty percent of that but that's an
mlb role yeah the nfl has a different
rule so if you are if you're in a group
right because because like
look it's never one person that owns
this team it's never one unless you're
like the even the nfl is different the
dana feels different they have different
is it 30 time i thought it might have
been i don't know you think he's less
than 30 10 actually even even and again
it's majorly baseball but even when
george steinbrenner was the boss i think
the most of the yankees he ever actually
ever owned was like 39 that's it right
yeah but again that's baseball nfl
specifically has a rule where the
frontline guy has to have the the wealth
the liquid and we shouldn't be in the
business of deciding what type of
minority to your to your point i mean
the uh owner of the jaguars right yeah
he's pakistani yeah i think shaheed khan
and his son is doing amazing things with
aew professional wrestling by the way so
right that's a whole nother shout out
podcast shout out to aeww
bezos is going to own a team he could
own the whole damn league if you wanted
to he could buy every team uh but
especially have any interest in it
outside of the fact that the the nfl is
just a non-stop atm machine that's it i
think he looks at it as a straight
investment i mean that's true i don't
think i think about that boys club
owning the nfl is like the pinnacle of
owning something hey i'll tell you
another thing when you have guys like
that that are that powerful and that big
and they're coming off a marriage that
maybe didn't go well and they're now
onto a second one where there was
someone younger more vibrant
they can drive you into doing things
you're not sure you always wanted to do
these women have power if his girlfriend
is really interested in him owning an
nfl team he can go buy one just like he
could go buy a new sports car or an
average person could go do that so he's
going to be an owner in professional
sports the nfl is the best it's the only
one that makes sense he's not going to
own an nhl team right seattle's already
taken care of in that regard and they've
all increased in value they've all
increased in value they go constantly
it's possible for it to go down you
might talk about tampa bay later um and
a certain quarterback but um
the bucks increased 29
in value not bad just by him showing up
just by saying 660 million dollar
increase yeah
i like john elway as a potential owner
he's gonna he's gonna be that guy that
lays in the weeds he's smart and you
know what he's done as an administrator
and running a team he got a super bowl
he had peyton manning i don't think he
wants to be attached at the hit with
peyton i think john elway does this
himself somehow he might have i mean his
car dealerships he brings back brock
osweiler on the front side
that's the name i mean he comes riding
in on a white stallion and saves the day
hey thanks so much for checking out that
short clip from sports now with tom
zenner if you want to see another short
clip click right here or if you want to
see the entire episode click right here
thanks for watching everybody
[Music]